معقل تنظيم داعش بالرقه في سوريا كان
مسرحا للمسيرات والاحتفالات بمكاسب
المجموعه التي حققتها في انحاء من الشرق
الاوسط وبين عشيه وضحاها اصبحت الرقه هدفا
لعمليه عسكريه مكثفه بدات باطلاق صواريخ
توهو هذه الصواريخ ضخمه ومكلفه وتستخدم
عاده ضد اهداف استراتيجيه
جدا وقال بيان للجيش الامريكي لاحقا انه
استهدف ايضا مواقع لتنظيم على علاقه
بالقاعده يدعى شبكه خرسان غرب حلب وزعمت
داعش انها اسقطت طائره سوريه الاسبوع
الماضي فوق الرقه ومع سيطره التنظيم على
مناطق كبيره من العراق وسوريا فان خمس دول
عربيه شاركت الولايات المتحده في الهجوم
عليه في
الرقه هذا امر كانت الاداره الامريكيه
واداره اوباما عازمه على فعله مما لا يجعل
هذا تدخلا امريكيا منفردا اخرا في المنطقه
وانما هو تدخل يشارك فيه شركاء
محليون الاردن والبحرين والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وقطر والامارات ثلاثه منها على
الاقل لا تدعم فقط الاجراءات وانما تشارك
في الغارات الجويه
ايضا
ه